من بطولة العالم في الملاكمة،
إلى بطولة العالم  في التفاوض،،،
هذا الشخص الذي وجد في الإسلام دواءً لدائه،
الشخص الذي تبعه مليون أمريكي إلى دين الإسلام،
في بضع ثوانٍ كان يقضي على خصومه،
لكنه احتاج لجولة واحدة في مفاوضته مع صدام
ليصل إلى هدفه،
(عن لقاء صدام وكلاي نتحدث وللقصة بقية).. .
كانت حياة محمد علي كلاي بين المجون والضلال
بسبب شهرته العالمية ونجاحه الكبير في رياضة الملاكمة،
لكنه أسلم وهو في ريعان شبابه وقال
(اتجاهي نحو الإسلام كان أمراً طبيعيًا يتفق مع الفطرة،
فطرة الله التي فطر الناس عليها،
وقد استغرق رجوعي إلى فطرة الحق سنوات من التفكير المتمعن،
كانت بدايته عام 1960م)
...
أصبح بعدها محمد علي كلاي من أنشط رجال الدعوة الإسلامية
وأكثرهم عطاءً، وكثر ترحاله لمكة المكرمة والمدينة المنورة،،،
وفي إحدى المرات قبل أن يعود من الحج في عام ١٩٩٠، عقب
إعلان الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية الحرب على صدام بسبب غزو الكويت،،
اعتقل صدام ١٥ شخصا أمريكي يعيشون في العراق
ليضغط بهم على الولايات المتحدة،
بعد معرفة كلاي بالحادثة قرر أن يقود المفاوضات بنفسه،
وذهب للعراق والتقى بصدام،
وكان لب حديثهم في ذلك الوقت عن الرعايا الأمريكيين المعتقلين لدى صدام،،
صدام حسين من جهته فقد استقبل النجم العالمي بحفاوة،
وجعله يتجول في مدن العراق مع العديد من المسؤولين،،،
..
وفيما يخص قضية المعتقلين فقد قال له صدام حينها،
لن أخذلك يا حاج محمد علي!
ووافق على الإفراج عن المعتقلين الأمريكيين في بغداد،
وقال له: “لن نجعل الحاج محمد علي يعود إلى أمريكا بيدين فارغتين
ودون أن يرافقه عدد من الأمريكيين الموجودين لدينا”.
...
وبالفعل أفرج الرئيس العراقي وقتها عن الأمريكيين
وعادوا في الطائرة مع محمد علي إلى بلادهم.
..
هكذا كان رد صدام على هذا البطل المسلم
الذي ترك كل شيء وانهمك في أفعال الخير،،،
وتخلى صدام عن إحدى أوراقه الرابحة ضد عدوه الأمريكي،،،
...
إذا أعجبك الفيديو اضغط على زر الإعجاب واشترك بالقناة
وفعل رمز الجرس لنستمر بالمزيد إن شاء الله...